herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
wer geimpft ist kann ohne weiteren test
ins geschäft oder zum friseur
das hat der bundesgesundheitsminister
gesagt am wochenende jens spahn hat
damit denjenigen die schon zweimal geben
ist also durch geimpft sind hoffnung
gemacht hoffnung dass sie eben mehr
freiheiten haben werden beim einkaufen
beim reisen dass sie wenn es die ersten
lockerungsschritte gibt wieder ein stück
normales leben zurückbekommen als erste
müsste man sagen bisher sind in etwa 4,3
millionen deutsche bereits zweimal
geimpft bisher stand aber immer die
frage im raum
auch wenn sie geimpft sind da steht dann
noch das risiko dass sie vielleicht
andere infizieren
weil die frage nicht so richtig geklärt
war war bisher der deutsche ethikrat
auch relativ vorsichtig und hat gesagt
nein keine sonderrechte für geimpfte
wenn sie denn eben auch noch andere
gefährden könnten jetzt aber ist das rk
ii zu anderen erkenntnissen gekommen hat
das risiko dieses risiko neu bewertet
der gesundheitsminister hat mit seinen
ankündigungen mit in aussicht gestellten
freiheiten für ein großes echo gesorgt
und entsprechen wollen wir das ganze
diskutieren die frage ob es für geimpfte
mehr möglichkeiten mehr freiheiten eben
geben soll zum einen wollen wir das
besprechen mit professor andreas lob
hüdepohl professor für theologische
ethik und mitglied des deutschen
ethikrates schönen guten abend und
lassen dabei sind guten abend herr
übergröße nach berlin in unserer
hauptstadt studio und wir reden mit dem
staatsrechtler professor ulrich battis
ehemals professor an der humboldt
universität in berlin auch einen schönen
guten abend und danke dass sie dabei
sind
ein schüler oder wie gesagt am
wochenende hat der gesundheitsminister
auf neueste erkenntnisse des rk ii
reagiert heute hat sich auch die
justizministerin entsprechend geäußert
schließt sich seiner meinung an
ein kurzer überblick über den stand der
dinge zu beginn der debatte vor monaten
hieß es mal für geimpfte
sollten erst andere regeln gelten wenn
alle menschen in deutschland ein
impfangebot bekommen haben
doch diese haltung scheint überholt das
robert koch institut sagt jetzt das
risiko dass vollständig geimpfte andere
menschen anstecken sei minimal
deswegen soll es bald lockerungen für
geimpfte geben zum beispiel einkaufen
ohne test und keine quarantäne mehr nach
auslandsreisen wenn die zweite impfung
14 tage her ist den
bundesgesundheitsminister gefällt diese
idee es erleichtert die frage wenn wir
test gestützt nachdem brechen der
dritten welle öffnen sollten das wenn
man meinetwegen mit einem negativ test
zum friseur gehen kann oder zum
einkaufen dann die impfung dem gleich
steht aber da jeder sich ganz einfach
negativ testen lassen kann im übrigen
auch kostenlos testen lassen kann haben
sowohl die negativ getesteten weniger
impfen dann die gleichen möglichkeiten
auch die bundesjustizministerin äußerte
sich heute ähnlich wenn jetzt
wissenschaftlich belegt wird das von
geimpften keine höhere gefahr für andere
ausgeht als von negativ getesteten
personen entfällt eine wichtige
begründung für die einschränkung ihrer
grundrechte
deshalb ist es ein logischer schritt
geimpfte in zukunft mit negativ
getesteten personen gleichzustellen
die frage ist nur ab wann genau die
bundesregierung will am montag mit den
ländern darüber beraten
da drängen sich doch sicherlich viele
fragen auf gibt es viele meinungen wenn
sie fragen haben oder ihre meinung
äußern wollen dann her damit wir wollen
natürlich ihre fragen stellen an unsere
beiden experten und sie möglichst
beantworten ja es gibt schon einige
vorab schon einige kommentare lassen
schreibt über youtube ich verstehe die
ganze aufregung nicht wenn jemand folge
impft ist gibt es doch eigentlich gar
keine rechtliche grundlage mehr dessen
grundrechte einzuschränken von daher
müsste man doch sagen wer geimpft ist
alle freiheiten an ihn zurück deshalb
die frage an sie professor lob hüdepohl
israel
großbritannien da war das schon vorher
schon in der vergangenheit wurde gesagt
dass die geimpften ja eigentlich nicht
mehr anstecken können
das rk ii zieht nun in gewisser weise
nach und sagte es ist zu vernachlässigen
geimpfte sind eigentlich weniger
infektiös also volle freiheit volle
rechte zurück an die geimpften ja und
nein also zunächst einmal begrüße ich
sehe und ich denke das liegt auch voll
auf der linie unserer ad hoc empfehlung
vom deutschen ethikrat anfang februar
das vollständig geimpfte gleichgestellt
werden mit negativ getesteten weil der
erste wichtige grund der uns damals
hinderte sonder regelungen für geimpfte
sofort zu befürworten war tatsächlich
die ungewissheit ob die transmission
also die übertragung tatsächlich
ausgeschlossen ist diese erkenntnis hat
sich verdichtet dass das der fall ist
die hoffnungen haben sich auch
nachweislich erfüllt von daher haben wir
in der tat eine neue lage und auch der
zweite brunnens in der zumindest aus
ethischer perspektive hinderlich scheint
eine sonderregelung für die impfte
vollständig geimpfte einzuführen fällt
wird porös nämlich die frage ob sie
alleine solche sonderregelung bekommen
das ist aber jetzt dann nicht mehr der
fall weil ja die testierung also sich
negativ zu testen für alle offen steht
vorausgesetzt es geht tatsächlich auch
für alle offen
dann fehlt ein gerechtigkeitsproblem weg
zumindest verringert sich das denn es
wäre in der tat ungerecht wenn geimpfte
aufgrund einer ungleichbehandlung diese
begründet ist die also sogar
gerechtigkeit induziert ist wenn ich das
mal so sagen darf vorrangig geimpft
werden andere hinten gestellt werden
wenn sie darüber hinaus noch weitere
möglichkeiten sich zu bewegen wieder
erlangen würden das wäre in der tat
unter gesichtspunkten der gerechtigkeit
bedenklich auch was die frage der
akzeptanz der im strategie angeht dieser
grund wird damit auch nicht überflüssig
aber doch deutlich geschmälert
vorausgesetzt es wird eine
gleichstellung mit negativ getesteten
erfolgen das ist aus meiner perspektive
ethisch nicht nur legitim sondern sogar
geboten würde man sie nämlich einer test
vielleicht unterziehen dann würden test
kapazitäten gebunden die eigentlich
überflüssig sind also insofern kann ich
herrn sparen und auf lambrecht in diesem
punkt nur zustimmen
jetzt frage an sie erwarte sie am schon
sehr deutlich gesagt ja das sind rechte
die müssen dringend zurückgegeben werden
wo und welche rechte denn genau
freiheiten würden sie sagen müssen den
geimpften schnell zurück gegeben werden
nun die grundrechte die eingeschränkt
werden insbesondere die
bewegungsfreiheit auf einschließlich
verreisen freiheit zumindest in
deutschland und das recht zu
demonstrieren dann gelockert werden das
rechte kirchen zu besuchen
religionsausübung im kern und die
allgemeine bewegungsfreiheit sowieso
jetzt schreibt gerade andrea über
youtube also läuft es doch indirekt dann
auf eine impfpflicht hinaus nicht
geimpft heißt pech gehabt obwohl ich
mich vorbildlich schütze ist das
wirklich gerecht habath ist also wie sie
es ist ja schon von meinem vorredner
viel über gerechtigkeit gesagt worden
gerechtigkeit ist etwas anderes als ich
und als verfassungsrechtler sage ich nur
was nicht ganz einfach
grundrechte können nur aufgrund
besonderer gründe eingeschränkt werden
individuell und wenn andere menschen
noch nicht geimpft sind und infektiös
sind oder sein können geimpft hingegen
nicht dann ist das ein großer
unterschied und dann mit kann daran sehr
wohl muss auch daran sehr wohl muss das
folgen haben und insofern habe man
insofern nicht von einer impfpflicht
sprechen es ist vielmehr so dass gewisse
es muss gesichert sein dass nicht nur
eine ganz kleine schicht
gewünscht ist und er so man muss eine
gesicherte wissenschaftliche basis haben
dass man nicht infektiös ist sowie dass
das jetzt angedeutet hat und dann muss
es natürlich auch eine menge leben von
menschen die er im sind und oder eben
wie es ja auch mal angesprochen worden
ist neben minister an dass die
nachweisen können durch testung dass sie
nicht infektionen sind also insofern
eine impfpflicht besteht auch nicht und
kate hören jeder hat die chance entweder
durch in absehbarer zeit oder durch
individuelle test zu beweisen dass sie
nicht
jetzt kommt allerdings natürlich eine
sehr treffende frage bzw anmerkung von
tom bock über youtube wie sieht es denn
mit den freiheiten der kinder aus denn
da ist es ja so dass es da wohl in
kürzester zeit keinen impfstoff geben
wird beyond wird ab 16 geübt
andere impfstoffe ab 18 also ein kind
was 12 14 ist wie sieht es denn da aus
halo hüdepohl ja aber da bin ich
optimistisch
erstens müssen nicht alle kinder und
jugendlichen durch geimpft sein damit
und das ist ganz wichtig das betont auch
der ethik hat immer wieder und das wird
immer wieder auch vergessen in der
öffentlichen debatte
es geht nicht darum das virus zu
verbannen obwohl alle begeistert werden
werden wenn das der fall wäre sondern
und nur so lassen sich die
schwerwiegende eingriffe in die
grundrechte rechtfertigen wenn die
primären im ziele erreicht sind und das
bedeutet die verhinderung schwerer oder
tödlicher verläufe und damit verbunden
ein kollaps des gesundheitssystems
und wenn das erreicht wird und das wird
nicht erst dann erreicht wenn kinder und
jugendliche geimpft werden sondern das
wird erreicht wenn die gesamtbevölkerung
bei etwa 70
durch geimpft ist dann müssen egal ob
geimpft oder ungeimpft für alle personen
die grundrechts einschränkungen
zurückgenommen werden wie gesagt
unabhängig der frage ob man freiwillig
sich nicht impfen lassen will oder ob
man auch nicht geimpft werden kann es
gibt auch eine bestimmte gruppe der der
bevölkerung etwa drei bis vier prozent
die dürfen sich nicht impfen lassen
aufgrund bestehender vorerkrankungen und
dergleichen
aber das kann nicht deren nachteil sein
dann muss für alle müssen die
grundrechts einschränkungen
zurückgenommen werden und nochmals auch
jetzt haben wir schon die situation dass
vermutlich bereits ab sommer kinder
zwischen 12 und 16 mit dem biontech
weiter im stoff geimpft werden können
das ist natürlich das ziel auch sie
müssen natürlich befreit werden lassen
sie mich aber doch noch ein satz zum
thema impfpflicht sagen oder diese
hinter hintertür
ich mache einen wichtigen unterschied
zwischen der phase in dem viele
impfwillige sich noch nicht impfen
lassen können aufgrund der knappheit und
weil sie nicht priorisiert wird und der
situation wo für alle eine impfangebot
zur verfügung steht und da muss ich
ihnen sehr offen sagen dann muss jeder
und jede für sich entscheiden ob sie
freiwillig auf den impfschutz verzichtet
das ist zu respektieren
aber es kann in einer gesellschaft nicht
angehen dass man sagt also die vorteile
haften bei mir an
also tesla im prinzip die nachteile die
ich durch eine freie entscheidung
allerdings auch eingehen müssen die
prallen bei mir ab das muss ihnen die
verantwortung eines jeden und einer
jeden gelegt werden darüber zu
entscheiden das ist auch heute schon der
fall denn bestimmte fernreisen kann ich
auch nicht dann machen wenn ich
bestimmte impfungen nicht übernehme und
da muss ich mir überlegen will ich diese
farbe reise machen da muss ich geimpft
werden will ich wichtig impfen lassen da
muss ich eben hat schlicht auf eine
fernreise verzichten das ist nun mal so
auch das ist ausdruck einer frei
verantwortlichen selbst bestimmungen in
unserer gesellschaft und das muss
akzeptiert werden jetzt eine frage an
professor backes es gibt das kennen sie
ein beispiel
da kann man jetzt sich vielleicht die
haare raufen es gibt ein seniorenheim in
lörrach da hat das seniorenheim jetzt
eine verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt
denn obwohl fast alle heimbewohner
geimpft sind zweimal geimpft sehen sagen
behörden und alle zuständigkeiten dass
auch weiterhin die geimpften nicht in
der kantine gemeinsam essen würden die
pfleger und so weiter sagen dort eben
was man den menschen dazu mutet ist
fürchterlich klingt so ein bisschen wie
die geschichte aus absurdistan aber es
ist so dass eben alle vorinstanzen das
sozusagen untersagt haben und jetzt das
seniorenheim und einer der senioren dort
verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt haben
ist das wirklich so absurdistan die
stiftung patientenschutz sagt das ist
tatsächlich gängige praxis in vielen der
12.000 pflegeheim nun der punkt ist jan
er die genehmigung ist versagt worden
mit der begründung dass nach dem baden
württembergischen verordnung gaststätten
und cafés und andere einrichtungen
gastronomische einrichtungen nicht
benutzt werden dürfen
das ist die begründung dabei wird aber
übersehen dass diese diese begründung
die 1 zugeschnitten ist auch allgemeinen
publikumsverkehr der typischerweise in
gastronomiebetrieben jahren vorherrscht
und hier ist es eben so es ist eine
geschlossene gesellschaft
und insofern bin ich ganz sicher was man
selten sagen kann aber in diesem fall
ganz sicher das wird vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht keinen bestand
haben ich rechne sogar damit dass sich
die lage eher ausscheidende werden weil
man sich vorher einigen
ich glaube nicht dass angesichts der
jetzt dienste fraktion ernst
vertreter der behörden noch sagen können
also ihr könnt jetzt ihr fallt unter
dieses verbot und das wägen wir weitaus
das wusste der konkreten situation
angepasst werden und auch vernünftiger
restriktive auslegung der verordnung
müsste man heute schon sagen dass da
stattfinden sofern sichergestellt ist
das nicht was ich ja auch den größerem
umfang oder überhaupt zutritt haben und
dort auch westen aber wir haben es jetzt
nochmal gesagt also da würden sie eher
mit dem fall sagen das ist wirklich
absurdistan und das wird wahrscheinlich
bald beendet aber halten wir uns
gemeinsam doch noch mal auch vor augen
wir haben etwa 4,3 millionen deutsche
die geimpft sind zweifach geimpft sind
für die das also jetzt sozusagen
spannend wird wenn wir uns über
freiheiten und neue möglichkeiten
unterhalt das heißt aber auch 79
millionen ich ja zum beispiel auch sind
eben noch nicht doppelt geimpft noch gar
nicht geimpft
und wenn ich jetzt also nun sehe dass
der einen dann reisen kann alle
möglichen freiheiten auf einmal hat die
ich nicht habe obwohl ich ja dringend
darauf warte geimpft zu werden kann dann
nicht doch ein gewisser neid entstehen
so das was der ethikrat ja im februar
formuliert hat solange sich nicht alle
personen impfen lassen können würde ein
teil der bevölkerung eine individuelle
rücknahme staatlicher
freiheitsbeschränkung nur für bereits
geimpfte als ungerecht empfinden was
sagen sie da heimat ist ja das habe ich
ja schon angedeutet dass sie diesen
gerechtigkeits glück nicht teile
es geht hier um individuelle rechte
grundrechte die unveräußerlich sind um
die insel abzustimmen sind das einzige
problem was ich aktien und dass wenn die
voraussetzungen im konkreten einzelfall
für eine beschränkung der grundrechte
nicht von dem buch und das ist der fall
wenn sichergestellt ist dass die der die
person geben statt also und nicht mehr
infektiös ist und wenn sichergestellt
ist dass es eine absehbare chance gibt
dass die sogenannten immunität dann habe
ich erreicht wird also eine größere
anzahl von gehen da ist 70 prozent wird
wohin genannt dann kann meines erachtens
dieses gefühl was vom ethikrat in meiner
ansicht so lang als diskriminierung
bezahlt worden ist
ich kann
die greifen das ist kein argument das
ist mein haus meine grundrechte
individuell verbiete es gibt nun mal
eine zuschrift von andreas es der sagt
ich bin seit über einem jahr zu hause
eingesperrt um risikogruppen zu schützen
ich verstehe dass jetzt so also um die
älteren die wie man immer sagt die
wohlhabenden gruppen und jetzt sollen
auch diese also gerade diese gruppen
wieder zur normalität zurückkehren
sprich die älteren sind geimpft die
können dann wieder alles machen reisen
was wir jetzt mal hier in der theorie
diskutieren während ich weiter warten
muss auf impfstoff etc wo ist das ganze
denn bitteschön ethisch sagt andreas es
nun dass es geht hier nicht um ethik in
erster linie geht und individuelle nein
es geht in erster linie um individuelle
rechte die die personen die games sind
haben keinen geben keine veranlassung
mehr dass sie nicht reisen dürfen oder
beziehungsweise nicht mehr
diese strenge auflagen erfüllen hinzu
kommt dass diejenigen die nicht geben
hält ja schnelltest machen kann und
damit die gleiche situation an das ist
doch einfach das stimmt auch in der
wirklichkeit gar das war vom halben jahr
war das anders ja aber inzwischen sind
die möglichkeit stellt es zu bekommen
doch so weit fortgeschritten und lasse
und dass die chancen werden auch
innerhalb weniger wochen weit
fortgeschritten sein dass diese
problematik dass es menschen in einer
anzahl von menschen gibt die nicht groß
wird das ganze leben und das muss im
berücksichtigt werden
politisch kann man natürlich sagen im
moment haben wir die hohen ziele
brauchen jetzt kein risiko eingehen für
eine übergangszeit machen wir jetzt
nochmal schaffen
aber danach ist die situation eine
völlig andere und das kann man politisch
rechtfertigen
also sagte wir müssen noch ein bisschen
zeit gewinnen und da wolle man kann auch
sagen wir wollen noch mal überprüfen ob
wirklichkeit steht wie das transmission
besteht wie das auch nicht ganz
abschließend auch das risiko aber zu
sagen ich sitze zu hause direkt mit
seinen kosten lassen sich dann sind sie
auch bereit sein anfang ein professor
würde wohl weil sie ja auch mitglied des
ethikrats sind also sozusagen diese
passage die sie ja mal hier alle
zusammen im februar formuliert haben die
ich gerade vorgelesen habe das heisst
also jetzt würden sie die auch canceln
nein in der weise nicht ich habe ja eben
gesagt dass das problem sich abgemildert
hat insofern teile ich die auffassung
von herrn battis ich habe ja gesagt es
gibt alternativen insofern muss man das
anders bedenken aber in einer situation
wo es keine alternativen gibt oder gab
jetzt richtig aber wir haben es ist eine
dynamik und es ist damit natürlich auch
eine dynamik in der beurteilung in einem
punkt muss ich ihn entschieden
widersprechen und das tue ich dann auch
den verfassungsrechtlern und nicht nur
ich sondern auch andere mitglieder des
deutschen ethikrates die
verfassungsrechtlern unter uns sind ja
auch einige prominente
verfassungsrechtler eben im deutschen
ethikrat wie wir können nicht punktuell
ansätzen wie wollen sie eigentlich
rechtfertigen wenn nicht ethisch und
zwar überzeugt und daran hat es keine
kritik gegeben dass es eine
priorisierung bei der impfkampagne gibt
nämlich nach der dringlichkeit wie
jemand ein risiko hat schwer oder sogar
italien zu erkranken
und das ist auch eine grundrechts
einschränkung der dänen für eine
beträchtliche anzahl von zeit von
monaten 68 monaten der eigentlich auch
ihnen gebührende gesundheitsschutz
durchimpfung vorenthalten bleibt auch
hier hat kein verfassungsrechtler gesagt
das kann man nicht machen diese form von
priorisierungen widerspricht sozusagen
dem dem geist der verfassung sondern
auch hier war völlig klar dass auf der
basis der grundrechte abgewogen werden
muss auch ab
erwogen werden muss individuelle
grundrechts ansprüche gegenüber einer
allgemeinheit und das ist eine aufgabe
unter anderem auch der ethik vorschläge
zu machen
gottseidank entscheidet weder der
verfassungsrechtler noch der ethiker
sondern entscheidet gott sei dank bei
uns die politiker neigen nämlich auch im
bundestag ja wir können nur unsere
richtigen bekommen damals lag hier die
userin ursel bartz sagt im grunde um
klipp und klar was der professor
battis auch sagt ich bin dafür dass
gelockert wird dass die freiheiten
geimpften zurückgegeben wird
ich selbst bin noch gar nicht dran mit
der impfung aber ich finde wer zweimal
geimpft ist und noch kurz wartet bis der
volle schutz da ist der darf dann sich
auch wieder frei bewegen es gibt keinen
grund mehr der denjenigen in seinen
grundrechten einzuschränken also ja aber
wir müssen differenzieren also die
möglichkeit beispielsweise in lokalen
zugehen kultur angebote wahrzunehmen
auf der basis wie auch negativ getestet
dafür bin ich ausdrücklich das habe ich
ja mehrfach gesagt aber ja sozusagen
davon abstand zu nehmen von den
allgemeinen regeln
das wird schon deshalb nicht möglich
sein weil ich kann ja jetzt nicht meine
impfpass die ganze zeit um meinen bauch
hängen und dann oben fahren und sagen
ich verzichte hier auf eine kur ohne
schutzmaske also auf eine schutzmaske
sondern diese formen die ja auch relativ
wenig eingreifen in die
persönlichkeitsrechte
ich kann mobil sein ich kann mich
überall hin bewegen und dergleichen
diese form von corona schutzmaßnahmen
können auch für vollständig geimpft
nicht zurückgenommen werden weil
ansonsten würde es tatsächlich zu
schweren verwerfungen kommen ja das
erstes natürlich dann direkt daran das
ist uns zu sagen sie da muss ich darauf
was zu sagen das ist auch völlig
unstrittig ja das letzte dass die das
musste ja praktikabel sein und in der
u-bahn kann sie können sie das nicht
feststellen das ist völlig klar deshalb
müssen die regeln weiter gelten
aber wo man einst festhalten weil sie
gesagt haben die verfassungsrechtler im
ethikrat da kann ich nur sagen da war ja
schon im september hatten sie ja schon
unterschiedliche positionen und die wahl
der verfassungsrichter war auf der
liberalen
lösungen werden sie und andere eine
schon damals jede position vertreten
haben darüber ist die zeit
hinweggegangen gott sei dank seien wir
doch froh wir müssen und wir müssen
jetzt viel an die zukunft denken es kann
auch eine gewisse übergangszeit geben
die könnte es geben schon durch den
lockout der wahrscheinlich wieder kommt
und dann haben wir eine situation in der
das will dass der grossbanken großer
teil der bevölkerung zu hause bleiben
das ist doch dann gar nicht mehr der
fall
die einen sind geimpft ja das ist das
ist die lage und dann ist das argument
mit der diskriminierung der die noch
michael noch nicht vom tisch
es gibt natürlich allerdings auch
kritische stimmen die wollen wir
durchaus hier nennen gerhard schrader
sagt über youtube mehr freiheiten für
geimpfte darf es erst geben wenn alle
ein impfangebot hatten vorher nicht weil
er wahrscheinlich eben darauf wartet
noch ganz bekommen hat und wir haben so
ein bisschen in die zukunft geschaut
herr lob hüdepohl und gesagt es werden
ja immer mehr geimpft et cetera in
absehbarer zeit der
bundesgesundheitsminister verspricht im
mai werden 20 prozent der bevölkerung
geimpft sein
es gibt aber auch sehr viele deutsche
die wenn sie gefragt werden große
zweifel haben dass das nun tatsächlich
schneller funktionieren soll
oder wird myself okay ein user schreibt
was heißt denn in absehbarer zeit die 70
prozent dass wir 70 geimpft haben und
wie sie schon eben gesagt haben
herdenimmunität vielleicht erreichen
werden vermutlich erst im herbst oder
winter erreicht bei der aussicht sagt er
eben schwindet meine akzeptanz für die
grundrechte nur der anderen dann doch
erheblich also das hat natürlich auch
ein bisschen was damit zu tun wie die
leute jetzt sozusagen versprechungen sei
es des gesundheitsministers was das im
tempo angeht ja eben auch an dem ja nun
aber sie haben die tests durch nicht die
testmöglichkeit nicht erwähnt es besteht
ja auch die möglichkeit gleichgestellt
zu werden einem geimpften
etwas mehr aufwand ich muss mich eben
dann regelmäßig testen lassen und dann
haben wir wieder also das szenario dass
wir in der vergangenheit ist nicht mehr
da und insofern kann man zweitens sorgen
verstehen aber das wird nicht sein ich
meine was berechtigt ist sehr berechtigt
ist wenn man etwa an die beschaffung der
diesen schutz denkt sehr berechtigt ist
ist jetzt ob du wirklich dass jetzt dazu
kommt dass so rasch geimpft
wenn das nicht der fall ist ja dann
fehlen die voraussetzungen hierfür bild
jetzt kommt noch eine berechtigte
technische frage empfunden um an sie
beide
wenn sie ja beide sagen ja es soll
möglichkeiten geben für die die geimpft
werden christopher allein schreibt über
youtube wie soll die oder fragt über
youtube wie soll denn die impfung
nachgewiesen werden
der aktuelle impfpass ist ja alles
andere als fälschungssicher die der
punkt dass jetzt ein digitaler
fälschungssicherer pass entwickelt wird
das wird ja gar nicht mal so zu sagen
diskutiert was es in israel daneben gibt
dass man sagt da gibt es ein sicheres
system mit dem jeder nachweisen kann ich
bin tatsächlich geimpft was haben wir
bisher haben das kleine gelbe heftchen
in dem ein kleiner sticker ist wie sehen
sie ist man ist eine frage die man
stellen muss und wo wir vielleicht in
deutschland auch gar nicht so weit sind
gedanklich oder da bin ich etwas anderer
auffassung so weit ich das mitbekommen
ist er im rahmen der europäischen
regelung sitzt die europäische
kommission dabei diesen greenpeace zwar
tatsächlich ein bisschen deine idee
vorgestellt worden aber überhaupt
keinerlei details wieder aussehen soll
das haben wir vor ein paar wochen
gehörte aber keinerlei details darüber
gehört wie das ganze funktionieren soll
so aussehen soll ja das muss gesichert
sein wenn das nicht gesichert ist also
wenn der/die fälschungssicher ist dann
fällt natürlich alles hinweg aber mit
verlaub da bin ich als ethiker natürlich
über fragt inwieweit das technisch
überhaupt realisierbar ist aber da
vermute ich mal wird es eine technisch
sichere möglichkeit geben dass
fälschungssicher auszugestalten aber das
ist natürlich die grundlage über die wir
auf der wii überhaupt erstmal weiter
diskutieren können
völlig klar das ist völlig richtig aber
da bin ich auch der meinung die stempel
in den kleinen mädchen ist jetzt
erreicht natürlich nicht da sind sich
doch alle eigentlich aber wir müssen
auch nicht das sage ich ganz deutlich
auf die eu warten wir haben schon in
diesen prozess schon sehr oft auf
ehrenwerten gründen auch die eu wartet
was ja auch zu sehr negativen ergebnis
geführt hat für deutschland kann man
durchaus eigene fälschungssichere lösung
finden muss nicht auf die eu warten
das wäre wünschenswert wenn die eu das
war schon würde schon wegen der
freizügigkeit in europa aber dann ja
aber warten müssen wir darauf nicht und
wenn schenken wird daneben und
ausgehöhlt dadurch das muss man in aller
härte sagen dass man eben nur in
deutschland mit den deutschen ausweis
reisen kann dann kann es passieren dass
andere länder das enger sehen aber es
gibt ja auch länder in griechenland und
auch in südspanien die der meinung sind
die würde mir schon viel mehr zu lassen
als das dann wäre sozusagen greife das
einfach mal auf man muss nicht auf die
eu warten schauen wir einfach mal ganz
spruch ganz woanders hin
die briten sind nicht mehr in der eu da
wird sozusagen auf der anderen seite des
kanals schon fleißig diskutiert der
premier johnson hat einen digitalen pass
für geimpfte ins gespräch gebracht will
ihn einführen
man muss dazu sagen da gibt es auch
wilde diskussion selbst tories also
eigene parteimitglieder haben da
fragezeichen aber das wird zumindest
diskutiert und wir können ja einfach mal
dahin schauen in ein land was einfach
gefühlt monate voraus ist was beim
impfen wesentlich schneller ist und eben
einen digitalen pass einen impfpass
eingeführt hat und damit schon die
freiheiten seinen geimpften bürgern
zurückgegeben hat nämlich israel wir
schauen uns mal einen kurzen beitrag an
skifahren auf den golanhöhen party in
tel aviv und urlaub am toten meer
israel lockert immer mehr obwohl die
infektionszahlen noch hoch sind der
grüne pass macht es möglich so
dokumentieren die israelis dass sie
geimpft oder genesen sind und was das
impf tempo betrifft ist israel ganz weit
vorne
mehr als 56 prozent der bevölkerung sind
bereits vollständig geimpft
ja ist das sozusagen unser ziel ist das
wo man sagt so müssen was genau auch
machen oder kann man vielleicht auch
sagen na ja das kann man nicht so ganz
vergleichen eben weil 56 prozent geimpft
sind und das haben wir noch nicht also
kann man nicht die gleichen erwartungen
stellen oder die gleichen hoffnungen
haben dass das jetzt in deutschland
genauso geht also so schnell wird es in
deutschland sicherlich nicht geben
müssen sie einfach mal eins sehen israel
ist umgeben von starken die seine
existenz bestreiten
innerhalb von 15 minuten ist das
geschäftsfähig bei uns dauert das zwei
jahre
das wollen wir nicht übertragen jetzt
auch unsere problematik aber das ist ein
großer unterschied
und fest steht die israelis was die
elektronischen medien angehen einfach
besser auch schon seit einiger zeit
wegen sie an das debakel weil mit
unserem kollegen überhaupt nix taugt und
es sind natürlich auch ein paar ich
meine 9 millionen oder über 80 millionen
das macht auch was aus und wir sind
einfach dadurch dass wir zu spät den
impfstoff bekommen haben also im
vergleich zu anderen sind wir insofern
auch benachteiligt aber tendenziell ist
das was in israel durchaus denke ich für
uns noch in diesem jahr
helau würde wohl der teile die
auffassung die haben nicht
unterschiedliche systeme vor allen
dingen das gesundheitssystem ist völlig
anderes die zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf
bevölkerung jetzt im positiven sinne in
israel gibt es vier gesetzliche
krankenversicherungen die sogar das
gesundheitssystem nicht nur finanzieren
sondern sogar bestellen also
bewirtschaften von daher haben sie
völlig andere zugriffsmöglichkeiten die
positiven sinne auf die bevölkerung als
etwa hier in deutschland perspektivisch
muss das natürlich so laufen und ich
gestehe hier freimütig dass ich doch
noch mal etwas gegen hahn bhattis
argumentieren möchte was heißt hier zu
spät wir haben sicherlich auch fehler
gemacht aber wir haben eine andere
situation der zulassung und ich bin
relativ froh dass es auch eine
elaborierte zulassungs prozedur gibt die
über die europäische union passiert über
die ema man kann darüber nachdenken ob
man zukünftig schneller diese prozesse
schneller beschleunigen kam da ist
nichts gegen einzuwenden das wird auch
zukünftig notwendig seien aber dass man
mit notfall zulassungen natürlich im
alleingang eines nationalstaats immer
schneller ist das ist klar aber ich bin
nicht unbedingt der auffassung dass wir
die errungenschaften die wir mit einer
europäischen union haben und damit mit
einem großen raum haben dass wir die so
einfach über bord werfen sollten wir
haben glaube ich andere probleme in
deutschland dass wir alles bis ins
letzte bürokratisiert durchführen müssen
und das heißt also das operative
geschäft muss erheblich verbessert
werden
und das bedeutet natürlich auch
konsequenzen für die beschaffung von
unterschiedlichen impfstoffen für die
verteilung von impfstoffen und
dergleichen also je gibt es genügend
hausaufgaben zu machen die im nachgang
dieser pandemie auch aufgegriffen werden
müssen denn die nächste pandemie steht
uns bevor das werden wir sicherlich auch
noch bedauerlicher weise erleben aber
nochmals die standards die sicherungs
standards auch mit der ema auch mit der
stiko auch mit dem ak ii da bin ich im
grundsatz sehr dafür dass wir diese
standards auch in zukunft
anhalten wollen wir beim thema
hausaufgaben ganz zum schluss sie
sozusagen ein bisschen um hilfe bei den
hausaufgaben bitten denn in kürze in
wenigen tagen sv findet ja die nächste
bund länder konferenz statt und wie wir
heute auch noch mal deutlich gehört
haben aus dem gesundheitsministerium ist
eben genau das thema was wir jetzt heute
hatten die rückgabe von freiheit neue
möglichkeiten für geimpfte das soll bei
dieser bund länder konferenz eben auch
ein großes entscheidendes thema sein
was würden sie denn auf der einen seite
die kanzlerin auf der anderen seite
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten zusammen kommen
sozusagen denen in das hausaufgabenheft
schreiben erwarte es also als erst
einmal dass sie vernünftig vorbereitet
in die diskussion gehen das ist ja beim
letzten mal
die entschuldigung kanzlerin bezog sich
darauf dass man die arbeit gar nicht
gemacht hat aber kann ich nachts mitten
in einen völlig neuen und abgestimmten
vorschlag machen der dann nicht mehr
umsetzt weiß dass grundsätzlich der
vorschlag umgesetzt werden könnten hat
österreich gesagt aber mitten in der
nacht und ohne absprache dass zu machen
das war ein desaster und das ist das
erste das anständig vorbereitet wird
auch auf bürokratischer ebene das daran
fehlt es und zweitens dass man nicht
dass man nicht nur daran denken also die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten dass die wahlkampf
machen diese und das sieht gibt nicht
nur stechen dann kann man ohne hektik
vernünftige regelungen machen und jetzt
sicher das wird auch so gelegt
dann fragen wir den vertreter des
ethikrates herr löw werde wohl was sie
denn sozusagen mit auf den weg geben
würden vor dieser konferenz
also ich ergänze nur herrn barth ist
weil das was er vorgetragen hat ich
vollständig unter strahlten nicht als
vertreter des ethikrates ich bin nur
schlichtes mitglied kann also nicht für
den ethikrat sprechen und ich würde das
gerne ergänzen
ich erwarte und ich dafür kann ich sogar
schon für den ethikrat sprechen weil er
das nämlich mehrfach betont hat dass es
endlich aufhört alleine nur auf einem
administrativen ebene entscheidungen von
dieser tragweite
zu fällen wir sind der auffassung und
ich bin das teile das vollständig mit
dass vielmehr parlamentarisch
entschieden werden muss vorbereitet
nicht nur nachgesprochen im parlament in
nachlaufenden regierungserklärungen und
dann eine parlamentsdebatte sondern
vorbereitet ich verstehe eigentlich auch
den deutschen bundestag nicht mehr ganz
dass er sich das alles eigentlich
gefallen lässt und nicht zusagen aus der
mitte des parlamentes heraus initiativen
entstehen
das infektionsschutzgesetz dahingehend
zu ändern vielmehr den parlamenten in
diesem land im bundesparlament also
bundestag wie auch die länderparlamente
mitsprachemöglichkeiten einzuräumen
das gesteht freimütig das ist eine der
größten bedrohungen verfassungsmäßiger
grundsätze wenn ich das mal so sagen
darf dass es alles eigentlich nur auf
verwaltungsebene abgehandelt wird das
ist völlig legal momentan das
infektionsschutzgesetz soweit ich das
beurteilen kann gibt das her aber ich
finde dass im letzten sehr sehr
unbefriedigend also die parlamente
müssten viel stärker in die pflicht
genommen werden als das derzeit passiert
dann dann können wir ganz herzlich im
namen der bund länder konferenz dass sie
sozusagen schon mal ein bisschen
aufgezeigt haben welche hausaufgaben zu
machen sind wer geimpft ist kann ohne
weiteren test ins geschäft oder zum
friseur mit diesen hoffnungsvollen
spruch hat der gesundheitsminister so
ein bisschen zusammen mit dem rk ii
diese diskussion losgetreten
wir werden dann sehen wie sie weiter
geht nächste woche ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre einschätzungen für ihre einen
ordnungen und auch guten ratschläge weil
sie beide in berlin sind kann ich dann
sagen guten abend und grüße an sie beide
in berlin vielen vielen dank dankeschön
dankeschön nach unten